[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel
all consumed with tasting something
again that you haven't had in years and
years that's really what i'm doing here
is bringing back those incredible
desserts those incredible experiences
that have gone extinct
i put myself through this process of
resurrecting desserts because i truly
feel that a good dessert can change the
course of your day
i'm valerie gordon owner of valerie
confections and i'm also a dessert
anthropologist
the way this
project of resurrecting historic
desserts began
was in 2009 the food editor from the los
angeles times magazine asked me to
create a plums coffee crunch cake for an
article that she was doing
and it was this amazing full circle
moment because i grew up with that cake
i know that cake and i missed that cake
terribly
plums was an incredible bakery and cafe
in california there were eight locations
the last one closed in the 80s when the
article came out we literally received
125 phone calls from people going oh my
god i want this cake so the desserts
that i resurrected to date are of course
the coffee crunch cake from lums
i've brought back the
banana shortcake from chasen's
the brown derby grapefruit cake is
another cake that i've resurrected
and now is soon to be the coffiesta
sundae as well
[Music]
the
anthropology of the dessert resurrection
is really one of the most interesting
parts of all of this
i start the research process at the
central library
there is a room and this is a very well
guarded room called the menu vault
there are menus that date back for 150
years
i find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online because
you're really getting to the heart and
soul of the place you're almost
transported
into that place at that time by holding
something that these people held you
really are
[Music]
then i email a bunch of people or i call
a bunch of people who were natives to
los angeles or whatever city the bakery
was in
to find out hey do you remember this do
you remember that we always used to call
this the adult sundae because this is
the one my mom would eat can they
describe the texture of a whipped cream
can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not i'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then flavored
accordingly right it was little kid
whipped cream one cherry yes this is
amazing like you you have been
indispensable
i'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about reliving those sense
memories
it's sort of like when you hear a song
that was your favorite song from 1982
you're really thrown back
into that moment it's become this very
emotional very fulfilling part of my job
to bring these cakes back for people
[Music]
you